a rally for the president as election
day draws closer
it's mostly proto-long convoys parading
the streets of the capital these days
much of the opposition has been muzzled
our parliament made the law
we introduced sponsorship political
sponsorship
which stated that before running
for our violation you have to be
sponsored by i think 16
16 mayor or
parliament representatives when you read
about our
political you know our political
structure now in the nation
you just see that candidates of
opposition cannot
get this cysteine because they don't
have males they don't have
parliament representatives there is a
feeling of fear
a feeling of fear you know you don't you
don't really know what to say
when to say it and how to say it
the parliament dominated by the
governing party has introduced changes
to the electoral law
many say it's paved the way for
government to age out
serious competition with many of
president talon's potential opponents
either in exile or sidelined by law
reforms
the outcome of this election is expected
by some
to be a foregone conclusion and it's
also expected
that many voters will be discouraged
from casting their balance
the turnout at the last parliamentary
election was below 25 percent
of the 19s parents who applied to run
for the presidency
only three were approved including the
incumbent
the economy may have grown under the
businessman president before covet 19
but some citizens say that growth didn't
translate to changes in their lives
as jobs are still hard to find i saw
whoever wins must first tackle
unemployment work liberates
then security and low prices for food
we don't want loaders anymore we need
better security for citizens
so voters also say they want to see an
inclusive political system
after restrictive laws introduced before
the 2019 parliamentary election
shrank the political space it's hard to
see how that
can be achieved before sunday's
presidential election ahmadi trees
al-jazeera cottonwood